[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Conan O'Brien here this is my video blog
here's what's going on in my world I
really I just saw that movie Skyfall
really liked it definitely the best Spy
Kids movie yet it was cool to see all
the spy kids all grown up in British and
awesome alright time for my first
segment this segments called
hey nice hat Johnny Depp hey nice hat
John and damn this is where I show
pictures of Johnny Depp wearing hats and
I complement him on the hats that he's
wearing Hey looking pretty good Johnny
Depp yeah that's alright Johnny yeah
I look like a pimp or Robin Hood or
something and then there's this guy
right here that's cowboy Johnny Depp
right there
nice job Johnny Depp and then this one
right here he guess he's selling
newspapers in the depression I don't
know either way nice nice hat Johnny
Depp that was that say hey nice hat
Johnny damn this next segment is called
spot the Guzman spot because Lynette
this is where I study a photograph and
try to find the actor Louie Guzman in it
I've been told that there are three
Guzman hidden in this photo I'm gonna
try to find them all here's the photo
right here okay I think that's one
Koosman right there okay and I think
well that's kind of more of an obvious
that's what Guzman and then I didn't see
this one coming but there's that was
spot the Guzman now a word from my
newest sponsor Tic Tacs everybody
last week was the presidential election
it was a really big deal and I wanted to
do some political commentary so this
final segments called cats that are sad
that Romney lost touch said that Romney
lost these are photos of cats who just
still can't believe Mitt Romney lost the
election there's this guy right here
doesn't want to pay higher taxes and
he's really bummed out there's this cat
it's really not happy this cat thinks
the votes were miscounted in Ohio
worried about it this this cat is
worried about Obama taking away his guns
right here this cat thinks we need to
return to Christian values
well this cats just racist
okay that was my new video blog thanks
for tuning Tic Tacs Andy stop it they
only paid for one ad
[Applause]